hey everybody I'm embarrassing and I'm
here to talk about the Little Rock Nine
I can't reach you our story starts and
Arkansas Little Rock to be specific it's
1957 the Supreme Court has just ruled in
the case of Brown versus the Board of
Education that separate is not equal so
their local n-double-a-cp went out to
the black community and found nine kids
to go to Central High School the premier
High School in Little Rock Arkansas so
these kids are like we are the Little
Rock Nine we are nine visions of black
excellence we will go to school and will
change the world
it'll be great so then the governor of
Arkansas
Orval Faubus finds out that these kids
are planning to integrate and this bitch
Orville fart bus you can fight all you
want for bus anyway horrible fart bus
was like hey if these kids integrate um
the streets will run red with blood ergo
fart bus is bitch the kids show up to
school on September 4th 1957 the first
day of school the senior in the group of
the Little Rock Nine is Ernest green and
he is like oh my gosh there is an ass
load of angry white people this angry
white mob was like we don't like you you
need to go away we are going to beat you
up and hang you from the tree
[Music]
meanwhile on the other side of school
Elizabeth Eckford the ninth of the
Little Rock Nine is like oh I'm here all
by myself oh my god there's
mob of white people this is terrifying
they're yelling and they have signs and
they're shouting and they are like
hey you're white
I mean I'm like I didn't you're black so
that means I don't like you so she
gathers herself and this girl is g-dub
in face stone-cold and walking through
these people who wanna um pick her up
and break her into just walking through
like a G and she sees the Arkansas
National Guard they must be here to help
me she thinks she quickens our pace and
she goes hey these white people trying
to kill me and they like block her
entrance they are letting other white
students in what is the deal you're the
National Guard if anybody needs to be
guarded as me here now so she leaves
school she sits down at the bus stop and
the white people are surrounding her in
there we don't like you
you are poopy she waits several minutes
for the bus the bus pulls up and she is
like thank God I can finally get out of
here this isn't the last I will see of
you but also in can I just get a
education so that was the first attempt
and they lost so at ten number two they
regroup they go at it again in a week
they all got together this time and they
all entered school the same place at the
same time the Little Rock Police Force
escorts the children into school and
they say hey look let me catch you out
on the street any other day and then who
knows what but today we'll take care of
you they squirt those children into
school and they hold the line so that
the crazy angry white mob does not act a
fool
the angry mob they break through the
police line and goes into the school
they're like oh so much we're covered in
this ball to snatch you out so the cops
right so they get away in the nick of
time because these people are so angry
at the like beat up cops and push them
out of the way so they could get to
these children white people so they go
to their houses these kids are now like
oh man there's nothing we can do
I feel very discouraged oh these white
people are extra crazy they're very mad
Ernest green turns to the group and he
says you know what we need to continue
through to school because all of these
white people are going to think we are
to be with
we absolutely can't give up so bad I
knew that story of the crazy white
people of Little Rock Arkansas finds its
way to Eisenhower and he is like the
is embarrassing these white people
have my up how dare these people
think that they can use mob mentality to
overrule none of these words are words
that have ever come out of my mouth so
President Eisenhower says I'm gonna send
in 1,000 troops from the 101st airborne
not a hundred of them 100 would have
done it not 200 not 300 but 1,000 of
these people
the Little Rock Nine arrived it's booked
together and the 101st airborne is there
and they say hey look we are going to
take care of you today
we're gonna take care of you today we're
gonna take oh ok so they were like we're
gonna take care of you today they escort
the children into school they are
holding back the crazy white people so
the Little Rock Nine is like this is the
we did it we win everything hooray
for us so they go into school but once
they get into school they realize oh
now we have to deal with these
children these white children are like
ahaha you finally made it into school
now you belong to us we're gonna beat
you up every chance we get she's like
wow and they're like we don't know
exactly why we hate you we just know
that it's something our parents have
handed down to us and so we're just
acting in what we believe are their best
interests and elizabeth is like well I
don't know that that is their best
interest maybe if you just get along
with me and they're like no this
children give the Little Rock Nine hell
for a whole year and these little babies
are being the black Adeus black black
that ever blacked and it is blackening
up my soul okay so Ernest green
graduated and he was like oh thank god
these people almost killed me so Ernest
green walks across the stage grabs his
diploma looks out in the audience and
sees dr. Martin Luther King Ernest was
like oh my god that is dr. Martin Luther
Vick
he's like these people was killing but I
did it it was crazy
and then thank you very little gig was
like well there's nothing else you'd
have to do cuz you've already gotten
through it good job look at my nails is
a beautiful hi okay then the 40 year
anniversary was in 1997 Oprah Winfrey
had them on her show and Oprah Winfrey
was like hey Little Rock Nine guess who
I have on the show the children that
tormented you and the bullies were like
look back in 1957 we were little punks
but now we're cool dudes who love you
and we're sorry because we were mean to
you and being mean to black people is
not cool anymore so we just wanted to
absolve ourselves of that their
apologies were not up to 2019 standards
their apologies were frankly
but the Little Rock Nine forgave them
for all the terrible things they did and
that is more than ever so in 1999
President Bill Clinton gave each of the
Little Rock Nine the Congressional Gold
Medal because what they went through was
being amazing it's shocking that anyone
went through it mrs. children cannot
point out enough that they were children
so the Little Rock Nine wins everyone
else is a piece of the end
racism fixed everything oh cool
after 2019 I don't know what I think but
I love margaritas black people
you